in this video you're going to learn how
to multiply two trinomials together
we're going to go through two examples
so let's dive in so when you talk about
a trinomial it consists of three terms
the terms are separated by minus or plus
and so what we have is a trinomial times
another trinomial and you can see
they're right next to each other with
nothing in between which means that
they're multiplied together so how do we
do this well it's basically like doing
the distributive property three times so
we're going to take
3x^2 * x^2 3x^2 * 4X 3x^2 * 1 then we're
going to take -2X * all three of these
terms and then we're going to take five
times all three of these terms then
we're going to combine all the like
terms together so let's go ahead and do
that so we've got 3x^2 * 1 x^2 you
multiply the coefficients 3 * 1 which is
3 x^2 * x^2 when you multiply you add
the exponents so that's X 4th now when
you take 3x^2 * 4X 3 * 4 is 12 and x^2 *
X 1st is X cubed again just adding those
exponents 3x^2 * -1 is -
3x^2 and now we're going to go to -2X
now you want to make sure you capture
whether it's a positive or negative
minus is negative plus is positive so
now we're going to distribute -2X to all
three terms -2X * x^2 is
-2X cubed -2X * 4X is 8
x^2 -2X * -1 is POS -2X now we're going
to go to POS 5 and we're going to
distribute that to all three terms so 5
* x^2 is 5 x^2 5 * 4X is 20x and 5 * 1
is5 now you might be saying Mario you
know why did you do this like line them
up like this well you can just put them
in one long row if you want and then
combine like terms that's completely
fine don't the only reason I set it up
this way is just so that the X cubes
would line up the X squs the X's just
makes it a little bit easier when we
combine like terms at the end here so
let's just go ahead and bring down this
3x to 4th there's nothing we can combine
that with 12 x Cub - 2x Cub is 10 x Cub
uh let's see -3 +8 is1 + 5 is -6 x^2 2 +
20 is
22x and we'll bring down the ne5 there's
nothing to combine that with and that's
our fin result so you want to write it
in descending order from the highest
power to the lowest and you got it let's
take a look at another example see if
you can pause the video and try this one
on your own okay we have 5x Cub - x + 4
multiplied 2x^2 + 7 x -3 so let's go
ahead and do this problem we've got 5x
Cub we're going to distribute that to
all three of these terms on the second
trinomial so 5x Cub * 2x^2 gives us 10 x
5th remember when you multiply you add
the exponents
then we have 5x Cub * 7 x which gives us
35 x 4 5x Cub * -3 is
-5x cubed now we're going to go with
negx we're going to distribute that to
all three terms x * 2x^2 is
-2X cubed x * 7 x is -7 x^
2x * -3 is posit
3x now we're going to take the pos4 and
distribute it to all three terms 4 *
2x^2 gives us 8
x^2 4 * 7 x is
28x and 4 * -3 is -12 so now all we have
to do is combine like terms so we've got
10 x to
5th + 35 x
4 - 17 x cub Cub +
X2 +
31x -
12 and that's our final result so you
want to put it in descending order from
the highest power down to the lowest and
you got it I'll put another video right
there talking more about multiplying
polinomial together I'll see you over in
that video